speaking of what is not free is the
rental market has absolutely exploded
it's seeing an insane surge along with
the sale of homes
this is affecting both new leases and
renewing leases with current tenants u.s
rental occupancy last month was 96.9
percent pretty high 96.9 percent
but the u.s rental apartment units
jumped 500k in q2 it's the biggest
annual increase in data going all the
way back to 1993. the average rent
growth this year is outpacing
pre-pandemic levels in 98 of a hundred
nations
of the nation's largest cities the
national median rent has increased by 11
in 2021. they say inflation is only 5
percent but the national median rent has
increased by 11 compared to only 3.3
percent for the first six months of 2017
2018 and 2019. that's right the average
national median rent or i'm sorry the
national median rent has increased by
11.4 percent compared to 3.3 in the
three years prior to the pandemic and
renters in miami miami where it's always
summer are expected to spend 39 percent
of their income on the typical local
rental this is expected to rise to 40 by
the end of the year
and when the best business show research
team gets to work we bring charts we
bring grass we bring data so here are a
couple of charts and tables including
joe's favorite chart that we'll pull up
in a second high cost of renting the
cost for new leases skyrocket as
apartment hunting gets competitive this
is crazy
i mean it's literally off the chart
compared to these other things right
it's almost like 20
the only time it was negative was during
the lockdowns and and then the global
financial crisis
right so basically it's always positive
and it just has this kind of cyclical
nature to it but right now it looks like
a chart that a startup shows a venture
capitalist uh when they want to raise
money just
right up and to the right do we think it
comes back down at some point
it's got to come down but i don't think
it goes negative oh my god i recently
ran in an apartment and every apartment
i looked at oh you're not going to lie
was was higher than the zillow estimate
for that apartment building every single
one oh yeah and they were acting and
they were like oh you better move on
quick
i mean somebody just brought up a great
point in the comments how is rent up if
you don't have to pay it
right because there's no eviction
moratorium so how the hell is rent up
well it's because there's so many people
that are moving and because they
understand that people are flushed with
cash they keep raising the price john is
explaining that you know it's higher
than the zestimate i think is what they
call it right zestimate yeah rent now
pay later
hey right now pay later joe biden's got
the eviction moratorium
next month for the shelter you provide
me today yeah no problem no problem all
right national rent growth is exceeding
pre-pandemic levels duh
right the solid line is actually what
happened with the rent the dotted line
is what it was supposed to be
according to the trend obviously we are
much much higher but even if you look as
early as uh february march april and
into may it was still below where the
trend was supposed to be really just
kind of jumped up in june july and into
august uh remember that's when we
started to see five plus percent cpi
levels uh as june july um so it's crazy
to see how high this is up rents are
rising quickly everywhere this is joe's
favorite uh chart or graphic right john
this is eye he loves the advice this is
his favorite character he loves these
he says how do you read this joke as you
don't read it to us
can you can you tell us about decipher
the hieroglyphic as everyone has already
heard uh i'm the only one that has not
had anything to say about this chart yet
because it is not my favorite chart i
saw it a week ago i thought it was
interesting uh it was my contribution to
the show look at this it was my
contribution as a topic for the show it
got pushed back a week because no one
listens uh and now it hasn't made it on
the show what it is showing is rent
growth across the top i believe 50 uh
cities in the u.s
the 100 top 100 largest u.s cities 2018
to present as it gets darker red that
means they're becoming more expensive it
is essentially every single one of the
top 100 cities have become drastic
drastically more expensive over the last
year why do you like this chart so much
look at it it looks wild yeah
that's what he told me when he sent it
to me i was like that looks wild look
it's all red to the right
all red every single city you like one
of them crayon kids like like if there's
bright colors and stuff your eyes get
attracted to it all right so i mean that
is the guy with a yellow hat
yellow it's orange orange whatever
yeah see i don't like colors i don't
know any of them all right
statement
i get the point where you're saying on
the far right of the chart it's all red
very good very good all right next thing
is the affordable cities experiencing
fastest pandemic era rent growth this is
crazy
so on the
the bubble guy one axis
you have the rent change since march 20.
to be clear hold on don't be coming out
i'm a bubble guy now i didn't pick this
chart
it's interesting i picked the chart yeah
john what's your problem johnny bubbles
john you're bubbling that's a good chart
he says a thousand likes yeah it is good
chart all right i appreciate the
thousand likes thank you now we need 500
more get to work all right just kidding
we appreciate all of you uh rent change
since march 2020 you got percentages on
the left side and across the bottom of
the median one-bedroom rent in march of
2020. uh san francisco this is
fascinating san francisco has the
highest median one-bedroom rent on the
far right in the bottom but it's also
down more than 10 percent so it's not
only the most expensive but it's also
the one that people are dumping
trash
place to rent and they're moving to
other places so when you actually look
at this san francisco remains the most
expensive but it's still down 10
since uh march um or i'm sorry it was
the most expensive in march of 2020 but
now it's down more than 10 percent if
you look at something like a new york
city that's the really big bubble right
there kind of just under two thousand
dollars um and then you can look all the
way up and let's see what's in the top
here fresno
fresno has had the highest rent change
since march 2020. it's up almost 25
approximately 25
massive increase miami up over 10 san
diego right around 10
wichita kansas
i don't know what's going on in wichita
but it's up 11 12
even detroit
is up seven or eight percent what do we
think about i mean like this is nuts to
see wichita kansas is up ten percent
landlords in wichita kansas are getting
rich i think san francisco is still down
because of the tech companies there are
um have postponed people coming back
into the office so in turn people are
like i don't need to live in san
francisco and pay high rent and do you
want the truth or do you want me to say
what's politically correct truth only on
the show i think that nobody wants to
live in san francisco because they
literally don't know when they walk out
their door if they're gonna step in poop
on the ground if they're gonna see
someone shooting up with heroin or
they're gonna get stabbed or shot and
then they also that all happens before
they get to their car which may or may
not have been broken in it's like a coin
flip you still live in san francisco you
didn't like it i literally went back
there a year ago i think i told a story
one time before there was two incidents
that i saw one was i saw somebody
stealing from cvs
and everyone's just standing there like
you know all right man yeah go ahead and
actually stop it like
i was just like what like
you guys aren't going to stop them and
there's a security guard and the
security guard wasn't doing anything not
not a police officer like a gun but the
security guard was just standing there
just like watching and i was like all
right this is a wild place uh and then
the second thing i saw was i was at a
conference at a hotel and i walked
through this like alleyway and to go to
a starbucks and as i walked by there was
a guy who was like uh standing there and
he like knelt down and he had a coffee
cup and he knelt down he put the coffee
cup on the tape on the floor and when he
did i like kind of like button hooked
around them and i just turned and looked
and i frankly i was like this guy like
grabbed my legs like what the [ __ ] is he
doing and so when i turned and looked he
had his iphone
an iphone that he had put on top of the
uh coffee cup and then he literally was
pulling a needle out of his jacket
pocket and i was like i literally don't
know another place in the world where
the guy who's pulling a needle out
literally outside of starbucks also has
an iphone and i was just like i'm out
like this is this is why get me back on
the plane we went there we saw it we
were there for like 48 hours we sold it
in the first
first two hours i saw two homeless
people having uh yeah yeah yeah
yeah
wait there's two 2014 2015 yeah
uh is when we were like in san francisco
for like 48 hours or whatever it was two
days essentially big weekend and yeah we
were there for the weekend
granted most of that is spent like you
know inside restaurants doing whatever
we were out but
the first day we're walking through to a
uh we're walking through to lunch or
wherever we're going and some guy comes
up to us in the street he's clearly on
drugs like just obviously on drugs how
do you know don't judge people he was
clearly on drugs because he got he got
up in my like literally this close to my
face and was like drawing like in the
air and i was like all right dude just
wasn't used to someone coming up and
doing that in my face and then when we
later that day we parked to go to dinner
and we parked at a we parked the car
like a parallel at a park and literally
we opened the door to the right and
there's two homeless people are just
having sex literally right next to the
door
like literally right next to the door
john and i wrote
us like what are you looking at
yeah we were like all right let's let's
just go to dinner maybe we don't have
intercourse on the park sidewalk yeah it
was
wild hey guys thanks so much for
watching that clip of the best business
show make sure you like and subscribe to
the channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it